okay okay everyone welcome to the
afternoon session we're gonna kick off
the afternoon session continuing on the
topic of computations our first speaker
is Carl Peterson from the Ecole
Polytechnique of Lausanne Carl's work is
focused on using a variety of techniques
to understand the causal and mechanistic
underpinnings of sensory processing at
the level of synapses cells and circuits
and the title of his talk is neural
circuits for goal-directed sensorimotor
processing so I'd like to begin by
thanking mark for organizing today it's
been a wonderful morning and I learned a
lot from the exciting presentations so
my lab over the last five to ten years
or so has got very interested in trying
to understand the link between neural
activity and behavior and as I as a
still a relatively ignorant person
dealing with behavior I thought that
sensory motor loops seemed to be amongst
the most fundamental things we can think
about in terms of behavior and so I
think this is sort of how I think the
world is is that we have sensory input
that somehow comes in from the periphery
makes something happen in the brain
neural computations and the only thing
the brain can do is to create some motor
output and that inner to in turn create
some real-world interactions and so
we're sort of caught in this sensory
motor loop and that really at least for
me is the fundamental aspect of behavior
and of course there's many different
interesting timescales in terms as a
neural computations and the real-world
interactions and our overall goal here
is mainly on the one second timescale
we're hoping to understand what can
happen in a simple sensory motor
processing on about that one second
timescale and specifically we've become
interested in rewards and how rewards
can change sensory motor transformations
and so we're interested in reward based
learning and of course reward
is nothing but other sensory input that
somehow has been given some value to it
and so that's sort of what we're looking
for is loops here that in both
increasing rewards for the animals that
we're studying and so what we're sort of
really hoping to study then is a
situation where we provide sensory input
for the animal that then gets processed
through various different channels and
through neuronal networks inside the
brain we can imagine these as different
nodes different brain compartments or
individual neurons somehow that sensory
input gets processed and should give
rise to motor output that in reward
based learning should then try to
increase the amount of reward that the
animal achieves and so what we're
interested in is how reward based
learning changes the neural circuits in
the brain in order to optimize sensory
motor transformations that's the dream
of what we're aiming for and so in order
to study this we've been looking at a
very very simple behavior where we ask
mice head restrained mice to detect
whisker stimuli so mice have this array
of whisker there's around the snouts
that I'm sure you're all familiar with
we put in sensory information on one of
these whiskers and we do that by putting
a small piece of metal on the c2 whisker
the animal sits on top of an
electromagnetic coil and every now and
then we give a one millisecond current
pulse through the electromagnetic coil
and that gives a brief impulse onto the
whisker so every now and then at random
intervals with no Q this is dying on the
whisker that lasts about one millisecond
and what the animal needs to do is to
pick up on that one millisecond whisker
deflection and realize through a process
of trial and error learning that this
means that water is available from a
small water spout that's placed in front
of the animal and so we have a brief 1
second opportunity where water will be
delivered if the tongue contacts this
water splats aware piezo film attach
this water spout so we can monitor when
the tongue hits the spout if
certain contacts our spouts within one
second of this one millisecond whisker
deflection then we open the valve and
the animal gets a small reward and of
course these animals are highly
motivated water is rewarding for them
because they're thirsty they basically
get the water supply here on the
experimental setup and before we start
the training procedure with respect to
the whisker they already know that
licking is a good thing so we have a few
days where the animal goes through what
we call a free licking period where it
simply goes into head fix the water's
removed from its home cage and it learns
that licking is a good thing and it
sometimes obtains rewards then once the
animal feels comfortable in this
experimental scenario we then start
applying these whisker stimuli and then
the animal through this process of trial
and error needs to learn that this
whisker stimulus predicts reward
availability if it makes a motor action
of licking and so our sensory motor
transformation then is one from our one
millisecond whisker stimulation into the
licking so we're largely going to
consider two very simple types of trials
we always give the same whisker
stimulation this one millisecond
magnetic pulse on the c2 whisker we
always have this one-second reward
window afterwards if the animal licks we
open the valve the animal gets a small
reward if it doesn't lick of course it
doesn't get any reward and so that
mainly we're going to be considering hit
versus miss trials in one case the
sensory stimulus transformed into
goal-directed
motor output the animal receives reward
in another case the animal doesn't do
anything and we can think of those as
miss trials of equal interest but we
haven't studied it as intensely is what
happens in say false-alarm cases where
the animal spontaneously licks and we
imagine under those conditions there
must be internal processes inside the
brain that suggests to the animal that
it's a good time to lick that maybe it's
dreaming about whisker stimulation or
maybe there's been some noise or
fluctuations on its whisker that makes
the animal lick here in the absence of a
sensory systems and so we think we're
going to learn a lot about internal
amputations that give rise to motor
output from studying false alarms and
I'll show you a little bit of false
alarm data towards the end of the talk
of course there's also conditions where
we don't stimulate the animal doesn't
lick and we can think of those as
correct rejections so returning to our
sort of schematic as to what we're
hoping to find is that we deliver a
whisker deflection in the setup and we
think it's important it's highly context
dependent a whisker deflection if the
animals not in the setup doesn't drive
the same behavior and so it's more than
just a whisker stimulation it's inside a
much more complex context that we need
to study in more detail in the future
and we imagine that that whisker
deflection from the c2 whisker drives
very specific pathways the the
anatomical maps for how sensory
information is processed at least an
early stage the brain is well understood
for the c2 whisker and somehow that
sensory information then needs to go
through a whole bunch of different
stations and in the end has to connect
up with motor neurons that open the jaw
protrude the tongue and so what we'd
like to find out is how through a trial
and error reward based learning scheme
we set up this pattern of connectivity
which takes whisker deflection and
transforms it into a licking motor
output and so our dream then is to
understand we assume synaptic plasticity
will play a role here we'll be altering
some of the neural networks and of
course there could be multiple parallel
pathways not shown here so that's a hope
reward based learning and we'd like as
much as possible to understand the
details and how this process occurs so
we get a causal and mechanistic insight
for this extremely simple behavior we
nonetheless have quite long learning
times and so on day one when the animal
first goes into head restraint it's
learned that licking is a good thing so
it's firstly it's already been through
this free licking phase where at licks
and it gets rewards and now on day one
we start making the reward delivery
conditional upon the whisker stimulation
and of course it doesn't know that the
whisker stimulation is
predictive of reward availability so on
day one it looks just as much when we
stimulate that's these trials here is
when we don't stimulate and so that's
sort of an indication that it comes in
naive and then day by day the animal the
probability of licking goes up when we
stimulate and it's in some way
suppressed when we don't stimulate in
this the divergence of these two curves
that tells us that the animal is
learning to perform and what I'll show
you largely is it from when the animals
learnt to pick up something like 80% or
so of the stimulus trials and has
something below 20% or so of false alarm
rates and that's what we consider to be
well-trained mice so of course we're
interested in speeding up the learning
process we are trying different things
to see we can be better teachers of our
mice and of course ideally we would like
to have very very fast learning which
would be much easier to study but right
now we're left with this one-week
training time and that's more or less
what we got once we've trained the mice
we can then of course do simple things
like study the psychophysics as you
expect if you turn stimulation strength
down then in the end the risk comes
imperceptible emerges in was the false
alarm rates and that's just your
standard psychophysical curve and of
course it's very interesting to explore
what goes on at different places in this
curves and whether we can shift these
psychometric functions around but right
now we're typically working on
relatively strong stimuli where we don't
think that this is going to be at the
level where there are perceptual
problems at the periphery but rather
that there'll be issues with hit miss
differences that will occur later in
downstream processing of how you take
that sensory information and turn it
into something useful you'll notice that
still with strength up we don't hit 100%
a licking rates and typically that's a
situation where the mice just simply
don't always pick up the stimulus and we
think that that's probably because the
difficulty here is most likely the fact
that it's just a one millisecond
deflection of a single whisker that
occur
at a random time and so the animal needs
to be focused and concentrating for a
period of one hour so that during the
payroll epoch trying to pick up those
very brief single whisker deflections
that turns out to be difficult or so it
seems at least under our experimental
conditions now the nice feature about
the whisker system is that there's a
very precise map of how sensory
information gets from the periphery to
for example neocortex and other places
so each one of these whisker hairs is
embedded in a whisker follicle there are
sensory nerve endings that innervate
each individual whisker they have
mechana gated ion channels you deflect
one of these whiskers that then opens
stretch activated ion channels action
potentials are fired down this
trigeminal nerve glutamate is released
in the brain stem from there there's a
variety of different power pathways that
emerge the one that we're going to focus
on is the one that goes via films and
then from thumbless to the primary
somatosensory neocortex and primary
somatosensory neocortex that's where we
have this beautiful side of
architectonic structure where each
individual whisker is represented across
a somatic topic extend our meta sensory
cortex the bowel cortex that rules in
sensory information in on one particular
whisker the c2 whisker we have a first
idea of where cortical processing of
that individual whisker occurs and
that's an area something like 200 by 300
microns on the mouse brain so it's a
relatively practical tractable a bit of
new cortex with something like 6000
neurons that we think over the years
we'll be able to get to know in quite
some detail so we've been studying the
Barrell cortex for quite some time an
obvious question is whether the bowel
cortex is in any way involved in this
extremely simple task and so we did
simple experiments where we did
inactivation so the animal sitting
inside the experimental apparatus it's
picking up something like 80 percent of
the times when we stimulate and then at
some time reject a trota toxin into the
primary somatosensory cortex focused on
the c2 barrel column but presumably it's
diffusing
DX of course blocks voltage-gated sodium
channels action potential firing and
what we see is that there's a large
reduction in head rate so apparently
action potentials and Primus matter
sensory cortex are necessary for task
execution something similar with scene Q
X a pv to block ampa and nmda receptors
and we see that there's a similar effect
so it looks like glutamatergic synaptic
transmission and action potential firing
in s1 is necessary for execution of this
very simple task so that information the
sensory information apparently transits
through s1 before presumably going to
other brain areas which give rise to
motor output we can do other experiments
to try to investigate whether s1 is
involved and an obvious one is to try
and see if we can substitute there was
the stimulation of the periphery for
direct cortical stimulation in the same
way that all more and others so here we
inject an AV virus to express
channelrhodopsin it's an e/m x1 cream
Mouse it's an AV flex vector so this
expresses then in excitatory neurons in
primary somatosensory cortex again the
AV vector diffuses further than we might
want to so it's not a single cortical
column that we're expressing the channel
adopts min but it is located in promise
medicines recordings like in a cut
section so while the channelrhodopsin is
expressing over appeared about a month
or so after viral infection
we then train the animals in the same
task as before so we simply do same
whisker detection task the animal
doesn't see any blue light we just
simply train this whisker detection task
and the animal begins to pick up around
80% or so of the whisker stimbler
deliver and once the animals trained in
the whisker task we then start dropping
in blue light flashes and what we were
impressed by was at the very first 5
millisecond blue light flash that the
animal ever saw gave rise to licking in
more than half of the mice and by the
time we'd give him the second
optogenetics turn was all of the mice
had licked so this is incredibly fast
transfer of a stimulus at the periphery
that the animal knows what to do with
and reacts in a similar way to when you
stimulate the new
cortex directly and so we think the
reason this works is sort of the overall
simplicity of the stimuli would give a
relatively on subtle stimulus of the
periphery our drawing on the whisker and
it's something relatively equivalent are
dying in s1 cortex that the downstream
Serkis appear to be able to interpret
appropriately and generate a licking
motor output so that's very much
compatible with the homo and mucin type
data where you can do direct cortical
stimulation and change percepts and
actions we can also go the other way
around
where we can teach the animal to react
to an s-1 still muscle now we first
train the animal on blue light stimuli
a primary somatosensory cortex the
animal learns to interpret that action
potential firing an s-1 generate licking
obtains rewards and once the animals
learn to pick up these channelrhodopsin
stimuli and lick in response to it
we then deliver our first whisker
stimuli and now we find that again the
animal reacts nicely to the whisker
stimuli and generates licking and so in
some sense we can program this behavior
from an optogenetic estimable and
transfer that to a real stimulus at the
periphery so these experiments give us
some confidence that primary
somatosensory cortex participates in
this behavior and so of course it's an
interesting to find out what's going on
in s1 during task performance and over
the years we've grown very fond of
wholesale patch clamp recording and here
is a study from coucher so then kasha
when he is in my lab he's recording from
this layer to free parameter neurons in
this case the animals not doing anything
this is just that I wake head restrained
animal where we're going with patch
electrode pick up a cell it's nice we
can fill the cell we know what we're
recording we know that we're in a
particular c2 barrel column and we can
then look at what the membrane potential
fluctuations of these cells are and what
is striking I think is the overall
variance of membrane potential where if
we look at the scale Y here 20
millivolts and the timescale here once
and you'll see that there are
fluctuations on a whole variety of
timescales where you have swings of
membrane potential 2030 millivolts
sometimes on second timescales but you
can have equally large changes in
membrane potential that occur on the
millisecond timescale so there's really
a whole variety of membrane potential
dynamics and of course the membrane
potential that we record here at the
soma is being pushed around by the
integration of excitatory epsps
glutamatergic inputs inhibitory ipsps
that are arriving across the somatic
dendritic axis these are all typically
small and amplitude so they're typically
around half a mil volt or so letting
some tens of milliseconds they're
integrating across this complex
dendritic arborization and they're then
together pushing this membrane potential
up and down and every now and then we
had a p threshold action potentials are
relatively rare and layer two free
pyramidal neurons in at least primary
somatosensory cortex and so these spikes
and here are of course the output and
this is then the neuronal computation
and I think that's as computational as
we're going to get and my talk I'm sorry
mark but there we go
that's that's that's my view of the
neuronal computation here is the
threshold so for some years we've been
recording in untrained naive animals
trying to compare what happens membrane
potential with whisker related behavior
and now we're interested in what happens
during task execution and these animals
ask and I'm just going to show you two
traces from the same cell a hit trial
where we stimulate the animal licks and
his rewarded soap by definition that's a
hit trial and here's a mistrial we give
the same stimulus there's no licking and
there's obviously then no reward and so
that is the two types of trials that we
mainly stay regionally after the whisker
stimulation with a short delay of some
five milliseconds or so we see a
depolarizing sensory response and that
occurs in both the hit trial and also
the mistrial what appears more
prominently different in this example is
there's this late depolarization in this
case with a couple of spikes actually
potentials sitting here writing the late
depolarization and that is less obvious
in the mistrial this late depolarization
precedes the Licking by some hundreds of
milliseconds and also follows the risk
of deflection by some hundreds of
milliseconds so it's sitting at a
relatively interesting point
bridging sensory stimulus and the motor
output as a reaction to it now these of
course are just two individual trials
but for this particular cell if we
average across all it miss trials you'll
see that the whisker stimulation indeed
evokes a relatively reliable sensory
response in this early component we
think that's been driven by the
feed-forward foul McCorkle networks that
are providing an input to primary
somatosensory cortex recruiting both
local glutamatergic cells and local
GABAergic inhibition and here we think
that basically cells get clamped to what
appears to be a reversal potential by
these mixed excitatory and inhibitory
conductances this first early response
is pretty much invariant to the outcome
of the trial and so we have a relatively
reliable representation of the sensory
periphery in response to a whisker
stimulation we think that's good when
primary somatosensory cortex there
should be something reliable that's
being represented here and we think
that's in the form of this early sensory
response then at later times and on
average it's at around 15 milliseconds
or so after whisker stimulation here is
a little bit later around a hundred
milliseconds or so we see this
divergence between the two traces where
hit trials are depolarized compared to
miss trials that's also accompanied by
more action potential firing in the head
trial compared to the mistrial and
that's preceding the licking reaction by
maybe some hundreds of milliseconds in
this particular so here in this late
component then we have something that
appears to be a correlate of the percept
of the animal in the sense that it's a
subject if we think of this as a
perceptual task where the mouse needs to
report a whisker stimulus that's
delivered then we have a subjective
a percept in the form of the report of
the lick or not lick and so in that way
of interpreting this data here we then
have a correlate of the percept of the
mouse and of course in reality it's
something that precedes licking motor
output we think this late component may
be of some general interest because in
recordings from humans in human subjects
with EEG recordings is now work from
Stannis Lander Haines lab where they
probe stimuli that are sitting there
somewhere at the threshold of perception
they find that there are some similar
dynamics that they pick up in the EEG
across the posterior the early occipital
cortex so here they have different
masking stimuli that they bring in and
then they have a centered to the human
subject they find that there's an early
sensory response that has relatively
little variance depending upon what the
subjective report of the human is and
then there's a later component that's
large for perceive stimuli and of
perceive stimuli and so of course this
may be something that's completely
unrelated to what we see in the mouse
but at least many of the dynamics seem
to be similar and so this is one of the
things that keeps us working away I'm
trying to understand where this late
component comes from in our experiments
in the mouse and so we spend a lot of
time thinking about the local circuitry
where this late component is coming from
I'm not going to get into all the
details we know that the
parvalbumin-expressing gabaergic neurons
fire a little bit less on hit trials
maybe that has a permissive role and
allowing the local networks to interact
with each other we also know that this
late component is specific for different
types of projection neurons so it turns
out that it's specific in neurons that
project to secondary somatosensory
cortex and it's not present in other
intermingled neurons of projected
primary motor cortex and so there's a
lot of things that we're trying to
figure out about the local circuitry
inside primary somatosensory cortex we
also cost very interested in
interactions with other cortical areas
but what I'd like to focus on here in
the second part of this talk is how that
sensory response gets mixed in with a
reward and remember that this is a
reward
learning paradigm and so if we want to
try and make that connection between the
sensory stimulus and the goal directed
motor output we need to think about
where sensory and reward signals first
meet in the brain and the hypothesis
that we are following up at the moment
then relates to the dopaminergic reward
signals that were first described by
Wolfram Schultz and the monkey and I
think have been very beautifully by now
cheeky a cheetah in the mouse and the
result that they have is that if reward
is unexpectedly presented and they're
recording from neurons here in the
midbrain the dopaminergic neurons they
see that there's an increase of phasic
increase in firing about a hundred
milliseconds or so after a war has been
delivered its reward then this phasic
signal moves towards the reward
predictor and that's a very interesting
signal then in terms of thinking about
how one might learn the dopaminergic
neurons prominently innovate the
striatum and that's the obvious target
of the dopaminergic neurons in the mouse
also and so one place where we might
imagine studying the interaction of
reward and sensory signal scent is here
in the striatum where we think that
dopamine should be giving a reward
signal and we know that the neocortex
has huge innovation of the striatum and
so we've then started studying the
stratum to try and see how these reward
and sensory signals might mix so first
just to show you the part of the stratum
that is whisker related so here you see
the same image that I've already shown
you before so it's not actually related
to this Mouse but just to show you that
we do an AV injection to inject its
channelrhodopsin with yfp into the C -
I'll column and we then trace this is
now a millimeter or so anterior to the
c2 barrel column you'll see the axonal
projections spreading within primary
somatosensory cortex there's another
part of the projection here that goes
forwards towards primary motor cortex
but
want you to notice that there's a major
innovation here in the dorsal analyst
rydym so this is a hot spot this is what
we call the whisker related striatum
where s1 sensory signals and s1 are
being relayed here to this dorsal
lateral part of the striatum Tzipi in
the lab did wasn't to make patch-clamp
recordings from these neurons to try and
see what the membrane potential
fluctuations were during this same
whisker detection task and we found that
they're very prominent task modulation
in the striatum again I just show you
two example recordings here many of the
cells don't fire action potentials at
all so primary somatosensory cortex
layer two free pyramids fire brave few
action potentials but the striatum I'd
say is even worse these are all
straddled projection neurons medium
spiny neurons if you like and here you
see the membrane potential fluctuating
and this particular cell doesn't fire
action potentials we stimulate the
whisker and in this case you'll see that
there's a large sensory response there's
a lot of licking it's a hit trial it's
rewarded and that depolarization is
sustained for a long period is this file
different dynamics here false alarm the
animals looking spontaneously you'll see
that that's also associated with a
depolarization in this case and then
other miss trials a ver egde other cell
here that has very specific action
potential firing here the cell seems to
Marlys ignore the stimuli with which in
the end turned out to be mrs. it's a c2
with this depression very little
reaction
false alarm here the animal look
spontaneously again nothing very obvious
going on and here's a hit trial the
animal licks and here's a ton of action
potentials being fun obvious differences
here between hidden miss trials striatal
projection your honor so if we now take
the population data together you'll see
that there are very large and obvious
differences and hit versus miss trials
in stride 'el membrane potential at late
times when the animals looking it's
really extreme obvious this difference
but even at early time points where
again we have by
phasic membrane sensory response or
sensory motor response we still made the
whisker there's an early sensory
response and then there's a later
secondary component and here in stride
them different from neocortex at least
layer two free permits that we've been
recording this early response is already
different comparing hit versus miss
trials and so here there's an early
modulation that so far seen in Primus
medicine massive difference if you see
the spikes coming out of the population
so as I say we have too few cells that
are firing action potentials so muslins
analysis is sub threshold but at the
level of spiking there's also a large
difference in terms of so obvious hit
miss differences in stride or membrane
potential during test performance here
we can also look at false alarms where
we now see what the animal does in the
absence of a whisker stimulation and it
turns out that in these spontaneous
licks
there's also preceding depolarization
this is when the tongue context is about
the first lick and before that maybe
some 400 milliseconds so before that the
membrane potential destroyed room
depolarizes spike rates begin to ramp up
and whether it's spontaneous or stimulus
driven there's a major change a major
depolarization on average and straddle
so if this were motor cortex you'd
imagine that this is some sort of a pre
movement potential setting up a motor
planning or or motor commands that are
here in the striatum now in the stratum
as you probably all know there are two
major projection neuron types that is
the so-called direct pathway neurons
that so they're all GABAergic these
projection you're on so straddle
projection neurons are gab urging
neurons they inhibit the projection
neurons and they hibbett long distance
targets the direct medium spiny neurons
are died pathway inhibits substantia
[ __ ] pars reticulata
and
indirect pathway inhibits the Globus
pallidus Matic drawings here are really
nicely recapitulated in different
transgenic mouse mouse lines so this is
a place where I think that genetics is
really very clean they express quite
different genes in many cases and here
in a d1 Creed mouse we can inject an Fox
a vector to express channelrhodopsin you
see the affection side and the terminal
axons here in substantia [ __ ]
reticulata is an a2 acree direct pathway
again the injection side here and the
termination side here and so these
pathways are really different and the
mouse genetics really very nicely
separate seeds two pathways when we then
do our recordings of membrane potential
we then fill the cells with by citing
and we can then see what type of cell
we've been recording from at least we
can positively identify some through TD
tomato expression and so in a small
subset of the cells and so here we have
to put a courtroom ugly where we have
five cells of each category that are
positively identified fruit eat
made of expression we now look and see
what happens in hit trials we stimulate
the whisker and the direct pathway
neurons have a fast early depolarizing
presumably sensory response where's the
indirect pathway neurons have a slower
rising but after about 50 milliseconds
or so they're all equally excited so
there seems to be a brief period of time
where direct pathway neurons are excited
more than indirect pathway neurons and
after that everything sort of mixes so
here we have some sort of Egypt position
to what's been reported in the
literature where to date it seems that
there's very been very hard to find
differences between direct and indirect
pathway neurons in terms of their
functional activities in recordings and
it may be that it's sort of that fast
timescale of this whole behavior that
allows us to pull apart differences here
where
direct pathway that seems to be missing
now classically in the textbooks the
direct pathway is described as a go
pathway and the indirect pathway as a
no-go pathway and so we think it's sort
of relatively interesting that this
direct pathway has an early sensory
response that seems to be pathways so
there could be some imbalance in the
activity of these two different pathways
that allows the animal to lick or may
even in itself drive the looking motor
output this type of response could be
something that's downstream of reward
based learning
so remember this is where the
dopaminergic neurons send their axons
they release dopamine in this vital area
we have the primary somatosensory cortex
s1 neurons that are sending the axons
down here releasing glutamate onto these
two different types of straddle
projection neurons and what the theories
go right now in terms of the function of
dopamine is mainly that this would be
something that would change synaptic
plasticity at the glutamatergic synapses
and so dopamine acting on the direct
pathway on dopamine type 1 receptors
tends to enhance long-term potentiation
would then strengthen this pathway
whereas dopamine acting at d2 receptors
has at least in some cases been
suggested to be involved in decreasing
synaptic efficacy although I think
that's a much more dubious result at the
moment assisity the strengthening result
of dopamine acting here at cortical
straddle synapses to strengthen and
coerce LTP is a relatively good and
strong result in terms of our detection
tasks then we think that our whisker
stimulus serves as a reward predictor if
the theories of Schultz and Machida and
others are correct this should then
cause release of dopamine and that might
then strengthen the sensory input onto
the direct pathway and we can
until the indirect pathway that might be
how this sensory response here is
strengthened through dopamine reward
based forcement and there might be a
weakening here of sensory responses onto
the pathway and so potentially dopamine
related corticosteroid plasticity could
be involved in generating this
difference here in the response
properties now if we're going to be very
interested in what goes on here in these
50 milliseconds or so where we have this
imbalance between direct and indirect
pathways I guess we have to make sure
that a brief excitation of the direct
pathway can actually contribute
something useful to behavior and so we
made experiments where we put
channelrhodopsin here into the direct
pathway or indirect pathway neurons this
is the same slide that I showed you
before and we trained the animal as
always in the whisker detection task and
we're now after the animals learnt the
whisker detection task we then start
adding optogenetics dim light of either
the d1 or the d2 pathways of course in
separate genetically engineered mice
what it turns out is that stimulating
the direct pathway is very reliable
in terms of driving licking of the
animal where stimulate an indirect
pathway if anything suppresses the
licking response again very clear
differences between these two different
types of straddle projection neurons so
here we have data that's then consistent
with the idea that brief excitation here
of the dark pathway in itself appears to
be sufficient to drive the looking motor
output we think that there might be
interesting possibilities for dopamine
in terms of generating this early
sensory response here in a reward based
manner and so we're excited that maybe
this is one place where learning could
be taking place that will then help the
execution it's very simple sensory motor
tasks that we're working on so we of
course think that there's a lot more to
learn so we think that this is one place
where plasticity and learning might take
place it's attractive because dopamine
has already been suggested by many
people to be what signal and so that's
something that we're following up at the
moment ongoing research we now try to
see whether we can find for example in
brain slices a trace of synaptic
plasticity that's asked we also think
that it's possible that the late
responses that we see in neocortex might
be downstream of much longer loops where
the striatum here these direct
projection neurons these are GABAergic
neurons they are enhanced it trials and
they will then inhibit their target the
substantia [ __ ] pars reticulata these
neurons are also GABAergic neurons so
they have two at least two major
projections one is a descending one down
to brain stem and so we have a sort of a
direct disinhibition here of brain stem
nuclear and so that's one possible
pathway that will then drive a licking
motor response
the other major output here of pass
reticulata is back to the thalamus and
so again we have this disinhibition of
the film's that might then also be
involved in generating these late
depolarizations that we observe long
loops that are taking place here that in
the end are involved in generating the
behavior that we're studying and with
that then I'd like to close and thank
the people who carried out the work in
my laboratory
so Schenker sat-chit-ananda set up the
detection task Varun and Alexander's did
the optogenetic substitution experiments
tennesippi did the whole cell recording
since tridem and Damian and SIL vented
the object that experiments these in
life thank you for your attention